[Musik]
in der letzten folge einsatz für pilot
rohrer und seine crew von reger 10
nach einem unfall mit gülle gas können
sie mutter und tochter retten
erfolg für jetpilot philipp 7 er hat in
prüfung bestanden und wird zum
flugkapitän befördert und notarzt tommy
von biel von riga 10 im einsatz auf der
basis bern belp der beobachter als coach
die arbeit seiner kollegen und begleitet
sie zu einem schweren verkehrsunfall
die a 8 bei saanen ob halten ein traktor
auf abwegen
was ist passiert
[Musik]
der traktor hat eine lärmschutzwand
durchschlagen und ist weiter unten auf
den rädern gelandet offenbar hatte der
fahrer ein blackout
jetzt ist seine bergung schon im gange
der ältere mann hat schwere verletzungen
der brustkorb ist eingedrückt die beine
sind gebrochen das becken wahrscheinlich
aus liga drei bringt ihn ins
kantonsspital luzern
[Musik]
und lustigerweise bitte bitte
fotos koch wie durchflogen
tatsächlich wird sich der traktorfahrer
nach vielen wochen wieder erholen
[Musik]
flughafen zürich der ambulanzjet der
rega wird heute an einer flugshow nach
meiringen verschoben klingt nach einem
einfachen inlandflug ist es aber nicht
in meiringen kann instrumentenflug wir
jetzt mit dem flugzeug und flüge nach
sichtflugregeln sehr spannenden fragen
auf die es keine leichte aufgabe also
für den neu profitierten flugkapitän
überzeugt
im passagierraum des jets flexibles
berger und arzt massen von dass die
ganze besatzung soll den ambulanzjet in
meiringen präsentieren
wenn der anflug überhaupt möglich ist
[Musik]
nicht nur das wetter als anspruchsvoll
auch die anflugroute im engen hassli
stahel muss der jet vor der landung
wenden
ja
bern belp not als tommy von will geht
der crew von reger drei ein feedback zum
ring satz beim traktorunfall sind und
dass mir schon vorher aufgefallen ist
kommunikation und richtline oder das
dass der seit das mit china bereit sind
von 7 und präsentiere profitiert wonach
er gefragt ist es ist aber das ist
möglich extrem positives kalle albert
maier das erste mal miteinander zu
schlafen
denn jetzt hin sind von wiens aufgabe
ist dass die arbeit der kollegen zu
überprüfen
hier beträgt eigentlich pro tourist
gruppe sogenannter deal 16 das heißt die
piloten den piloten jacket richtig
sanität rettungssanitäter und notarzt
und ich bin ein star
matthias medizinisch gewinnen das macht
aber das funktionierte die linie toni
team katalysator in euren account
um die ist es auch wichtig dass man mit
denen team aspekt bespricht und dadurch
das funktioniert auch beim nächsten
einsatz ist hobby von will dabei
[Musik]
bei ausrüstung und abläufe sind auf
allen regler basen gleich tommy von biel
findet sich also während des lounge ex
problemlos zurecht
anflug auf die region moléson in den
freiburger voralpen
in diesem gelände kann der helikopter
nicht landen
die beiden ärzte lassen sich schwebend
absetzen
[Applaus]
ein wanderer ist verunglückt passanten
haben schon erste hilfe geleistet
die war unangenehm überrascht als ich
das knacken des knochens hörte ich denke
sie steckt noch der gebrochen ist es
waren jedoch legt ihm gut
ich habe meinen gönner beitrag gezahlt
die wichtigste platz langsam gar nicht
ja die stringente politik tun
bei diesem helikopter typ dem eurocopter
ec145 steht der rettungssanitäter
während der winden rettung draußen auf
den sogenannten dpa
betroffen
[Musik]
jedoch wäre doch im inneren wie noch nie
jan o
unser leader
neben und geworden
weiter unten wird der patient in den
helikopter steigen für den transport ins
spital areal
[Applaus]
rega center in zürich zwei
einsatzzentralen im gleichen raum auf
der einen seite für die helikopter auf
der anderen seite für die ambulanzjets
erklärt ärztin annina gerber welcher
patienten wand zu repatriieren sind
kritisch bezüglich ist unglaublich
leider ist ein patient mit einer spinale
muskelatrophie hat mit dem rollstuhl
logische wiesenhütter welle von palm
aufzüge und dann haben sie die bezirke
sogar ganz in der 68
und jetzt ist bei maria farina gerber
ruft im spital an
ich suche einen patienten er habe den
bischof
bischof kann ich mit dem notfalldienst
sprechen
der notfalldienst ist nicht erreichbar
die beratungs ärztin geht aber davon aus
dass der patient mit einem linienflug in
die schweiz kommen kann
es ist speziell im rollstuhl ist quasi
nonstop vollautomatisch
ich muss mich die mahnung sprach ich
denke die 1 80 meter überstehen
christian bischoff ich bin abgesetzte
für die repatriierungen mein vorschlag
wäre das mich begleitete oder
krankenschwester wo sie begleitet von
der rega aus wo acht schmerzen wo sie
korrekt kommen quasi lager bezirks ist
mobilisierenden in halver ehrlich jetzt
ganz ruhig und
extrem crew für das eigentlich ja
wirklich ja mit seiner behinderung und
im rollstuhl und wirklich ganz zum
zirkus ist jetzt mit nur zur satzungs
und lädt sich also finden sich stark du
anime amisia palma de mallorca wenn man
das neue werk mache und den wthc buchen
ist das praktisch nicht realistisch war
nach der 40 vfc okay da muss ich noch
mal mit dem patienten wird sie hc steht
für wheelchair carey einen dienst des
jeweiligen flughafens helfer bringen den
fluggast in einem schmalen rollstuhl bis
zu seinem sitz wch cmx kreist also das
dass man sie bis zum sitz brachte und
für das brauchen wir achten jetzt
gestand schaffen wir das gerne der flug
zu organisieren
das ist sehr unangenehm aber mir nur
gesetz trotzdem wieder okay
die flugshow in meiringen zum 75 jahr
jubiläum des militärflugplatzes ist
inzwischen in vollem gange
die polizei
die rega wird hier um aufmerksamkeit und
gunst des publikums
sie ist auf goodwill angewiesen 3,3
millionen gönnerinnen und gönner zahlen
pro jahr fast 90 millionen fanden an
beitragsgeldern und spenden damit macht
einer von ihnen ist kommt wo den prager
war und dann wäre es mit wieder
ausgezeichnet super und es entstehen
sagt dusy 100 jahre 200 kranke ist das
haus stecken
ein leicht gewachsen
wir sind dann sieht wie simyo gründer
dass man querfinanzieren und geflügel
aber nur für street auftrag der
ausländischen versicherung zum beispiel
diese dann für herum
also am stück das kann schon mal 25
dies gestand sie aber nur geschaut und
mich aber immer eine pflege und die tür
aber hier wäre wenn man nur platz immer
hier früh ins bett machen dass man der
öwa erwachsene schlafen wenn man wieder
aus zwölf 13 stunden flüge der sie drei
piloten und so über stolze vier piloten
selbst der ceo der rettungsflugwacht ist
vor ort
für ernst kohler ist es ein heimspiel er
ist im hasli tal aufgewachsen und vor
seiner zeit bei der rega war er
kommandant des militärflugplatzes
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
seit zehn jahren ist ernst kohler chef
er hat in diesem amt schon stürmische
zeiten erlebt 2013 nahmen die medien
saläre und bezüge der rega führung unter
die lupe ernst kohler verdiene rund
400000 franken zu viel für den chef
einer gemeinnützigen stiftung so die
kritik das ist diese schwierige
situation sie ich hoffe mir ganz
persönlich nicht einfach sind das zum
teil sehr emotional geführten
diskussionen da klasse cabrio standard
sie sagen hey potter das mal wirklich
hinterfragen externe berater wie szene
ob man jetzt noch ein richtiger maxi
laut dieser analyse seien in dieser
lehrerin stufen richtig genaue zahlen
gab und gibt es bis heute allerdings
nicht bei ernst kohler ist die
erinnerung an diese krise noch macht
organisation und letztlich natürlich
opel-chef terrororganisationen aber wenn
man wenn man dir das nicht das darf man
die funktion
viel show und unterhaltung in meiringen
doch helikopterpilot rick maurer ist
nicht nur zum vergnügen hier
[Musik]
also müssen sie hier vom programm zur
veranstaltung zusätzliche kräfte und
mittel auch sobald das trauerland und
und sowie und dezember neues glück wie
vergrößere das sie da bricht die abflug
immer aber ist natürlich interessant für
die gesamte region fliegt nicht nur
lecker sondern auch kleinflugzeuge sein
herz aber schlägt für diese jets
das war's kosten das war eigentlich der
groß groß kinderwunsches militante
wachsen
aber irgendwie hat man sich das land in
einer sache diesmal ist mit zahlte sich
aus und tc des alten cockpit wurde aber
militärpilot dass es genügt schon es
noch tausend worte
[Musik]
zurück im rega center in zürich
abklärung ärztin annina gerber arbeitet
immer noch im fall von severin bischof
der muskel kranken patienten der den arm
gebrochen hat
sprachen glauben offenbar spanisch aber
das funktioniert nicht so optimal dass
wirklich gut und jetzt übernimmt die
einsatzleitung den fall ein ambulanzjet
ist einsatzbereit der pilot wird gerufen
es gibt an nie sagt david und so dazu
tragen mallorca direktor mittelstand
rufen tage patient gebracht werden
nach der rettung zu bringen
wenn man eine straftat pilot philipp
sémon übernimmt den flug nach palma er
wohnt nur 15 autominuten vom flughafen
entfernt
die heute gesetzlich nicht gesagt habe
dass ich viele kurzarbeiter wieder nach
gott bis zur in parma naja wir morgens
druck 1000 dass er der zehnte wo im
moment dann aber was ich auch einige das
ist eigentlich gut in spanien wmf group
eigentliche problem gehen die durch
es waren sich
[Musik]
und wieder bricht philipp sémon auf im
einsatz für die rettungsflugwacht
[Musik]
in bern belp schließt hobby von will den
laien check up es bleibt noch ein
letztes beurteilungs gespräch mit seinem
kollegen matthias maucksch der seit fünf
jahren bei der rege arbeitet dies
spiegelt sich problemlos kommen die
kommunikation im team lebt funktion
standardmäßig zur problemlosen wechsel
zu rufen und dem moment hatte daniel
gestoppt
dann habe ich das auch detailkritik zum
tagesschluss auf jeder pass ist gibt es
pro berufsgruppe mehr allein checks im
jahr für die crew von reger 3 ist der
dienst aber noch nicht zu ende
[Musik]
das dreierteam verbringt 48 stunden am
stück auf der basis
piloten ärzte und rettungssanitäter
leben hier wie in einer wohngemeinschaft
[Musik]
es sind teamplayer gefragt die auch
probleme ansprechen
auf basis war ein beispiel dass das
haupt dass man hierfür bis punkt wird
der weisen euro ist im team ist wie sie
es tat rettete dürfen gesamte know how
to be das dramatisch und so endlich fit
to fly an diesem abend ist die volle
einsatzfähigkeit gefragt
[Musik]
politiker die mit klopfen es wird eine
lange nacht
auch rät maurer von reger 10 in
wilderswil hat picker dienst er und
seine crew dürften die nächte aber zu
hause verbringen im falle einer
alarmierung muss er in 30 minuten in der
luft sein
[Musik]
rickmers job verlangt flexibilität auch
von seiner familie
trotzdem ist die arbeit zu hause kein
großes thema neben auch dass
krankheitserreger hat bis kaufen
vorstellen ohne bedenkliche probieren
sie den wirt berauscht
es geht schon ich sauer regional
vorsorge treffen
und doch machen sich die kinder ihre
gedanken
außerdem macht papa stürzte das papier
piloten schulte macht es nur soviel vor
dem schlafengehen prüft rick maurer das
wetter und die sicht im moment ist sogar
zu recht trocken ausgebaut
erik maurer geht zwischen 9 und 10 zu
bett im wissen dass jederzeit das
telefon klingelt könnte zum
stromausfälle ich geh zwischen zwei und
vier
einen termin ist fühlt sich schlauchte
morgen oder dieses morgens an und der
tut ist dies eigentlich die 2
aber das objekt das im auto sitzen platz
vor und dann schon in weiß und jahre
muss und dass sie so zäh zu lesen
doch jeder nächtliche alarm direkt auch
die familie nicht so gute stelle und ich
mein geschont so kurz wie jahr also bin
ich froh einen mähdrescher zehn bis 15
mal pro monat hat rick maura
pikettdienst alles liegt bereit damit er
im halbschlaf nichts vergisst
der rega ambulanzjet ist im anflug auf
palma de mallorca flüge nach
instrumentenflugregeln das heißt
navigieren mit einer instrument auf dem
bildschirm darstellt haben konzentration
am boden geschlagen
dieses verhalten ist es den rollwagen
muss eine lehre und ist sehr gut also
ich links und acht einsprachen adresse
ein ambulanzfahrzeug bringt den muskel
kranken patienten der den arm gebrochen
hat
rega arzt andré kuska steht schon bereit
so lange darf
naja wie schon wie ich es im moment mit
schmerzen okay wir ein flugzeug gehörte
zur zeit der raum wo man benutzt
ich wusste ja dass sie das medial
kontakt und sich auf den klassiker
stoppt und den monitor
ok also
leopold
juchu schreien
[Musik]
die umlagerung muss gut vorbereitet sein
ich bin jetzt nach einer zum der
transfer macht oder ein
schmerzmedikament quasi das delikt
rühmlich wird oder aber selten
schmerzformen ich denke dass ohne das
netz der dorfscheune kurz darauf so
erheben wie ich dafür sie gut besetzt
ist jetzt ganz gut
rang 23
ok
medizinisch ist work sich haben und zum
beispiel schwierig zum beispiel wenig
genauer klage wird war darum mit 200
volt oder mal um leonie dass ich
schmerzen und sozusagen begriff spanisch
und englisch im leben bringen enorm
schwierig sehr fragen lassen gleich noch
klappt hat sondern sofort also hüten
auch zurückfliegen
gut
sind sie also mit den von - das los
perfekt
[Musik]
auch für die crew von rega 3 in bern
belp ist noch nicht vergeben
sie muss an diesem abend bereits zum
dritten mal ausrücken pilot simon macht
sich wegen der gewitter sorgen
es ist kurz vor 2 uhr
doch nicht machen das mittelstück
notwendig gewesen
der patient ist kollabiert
das ist alles was die rega crew zurzeit
weiß
[Musik]
simon looking führen prüft laufend die
wetterlage inselspital bern oder
unispital lausanne das ist die frage
[Musik]
sie war sie nicht wissen genau und mit
taktik auf das vom westen aber hinter
gittern zufrieden
[Musik]
täglich gestanden in 15 minuten
[Applaus]
produzenten die finnische reagiert auf
die krise reagiert erstaunt
bern inselspital die rega hat den
patienten angemeldet die spezialisten
stehen bereit
[Musik]
mit der übergabe des patienten löst sich
bei der rega crew die anspannung ein
wenig
[Musik]
das haben jetzt ziemlich vertraut ist
und jetzt bin ich schon ziemlich müde
und susanne christ den die rakete
fliegen und jetzt ist sie auch nicht in
den fasching redaktion muss mir mal kurz
anfrieren bereich und der mister
geschafft
die verleger starb
diese werden
später wird die rega crew erfahren der
patient ist leider geschoben trotz aller
bemühungen
[Musik]
eine lange nacht geht zu ende
nach diesem einsatz muss die crew von
reger 3 mindestens sechs stunden ruhen
[Musik]
will dass wir bei interlaken patrick
maurer hatte im gegensatz zu seinen
berner kollegen eine ruhige nacht
heute im team von regazzoni die ärzte in
china zurückzieht
der erste einsatz geht nicht in die
innerschweiz sondern ins hochgebirge
[Musik]
nach dem stand liefert die
einsatzzentrale infos zum fall
der pole
die rega crew holt in diesem fall die
unterstützung eines bergführers genauer
eines fachspezialisten helikopter des sc
heute hat benny wenger picke dienst er
hat die nötige gebirgs erfahrung um die
risiken einer rettung am ritzlihorn
abschätzen zu können
[Musik]
der rettungsspezialist fotografierte
situation für die ermittlungsbehörden
eine kurze zwischenlandung am seil die
ärztin und der bergführer
im sommer war der gedanke stehen gut
getan
dahinter steckt das radio
und bin ich glücklich rettungssanitäter
marcoule eia der winter gibt die
anweisungen der pilot hat keine sicht
nach oben
haben sich doch
der helikopter geht in warteposition bis
ärztin kemena notter den patienten für
das erste versorgt hat
anflug zur bergung
st
sich einbringen
[Musik]
ist aber dahin
sie spricht morgen kommt doch vorgezogen
darum möchten wir wollen
der patient ist betäubt von
schmerzmitteln mittlerweile ist klar
steinschlag hat ihn zum absturz gebracht
[Musik]
in der nächsten sendung magazin bringt
den verunfallten kletterer ins spital
der mann hat starke schmerzen
jetpilot philipp sémon bei
flugzeughersteller bombardier in kanada
sie minister eines millionenprojekt drei
neue rega ambulanzjet werden hier gebaut
und wie rega crew reist nach venedig sie
holt einen patienten der fast ertrunken
wäre
ich bin zufrieden
[Musik]